le salon Facebook
ça fait 5 ans qu'il est ouvert donc
trois ans et demi du côté esthétique et
un an et demi côté coiffure de ce qui
fait le point fort de notre de notre
salon effectivement c'est le côté
l'épilation au fil donc c'est une
technique qui est aujourd'hui pas mal
demandé et que les nos clientes
apprécient dans le contexte de une
journée bien-être donc personne elle
peut faire un soin du visage peut se
faire une beauté des mains se faire
maquiller coiffer donc pour justement
sortir pourquoi pas le soir et justement
surprendre son homme rentrant chez elle
le poste à pourvoir donc pour cette pour
cette personne ce que je recherche c'est
justement quelqu'un qui soit
dynamique et qui à cet esprit d'équipe
donc parce que c'est super important de
se sentir bien dans un salon ce sera une
coiffeuse qui qui aura que le but de
côté coiffure pas d'esthétique
l'ambiance de travail chez Facebook donc
concerne le sourire l'accueil la
personne donc elle aura comme tâche donc
de gérer
l'accueil téléphonique de
sa clientèle le
son poste de travail si vous voyez à
travers ce poste donc n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer votre candidature et nous
ferons un plaisir de vous donner une
réponse
vos missions chez Facebook
assurez l'accueil physique et
téléphonique de la clientèle réaliser
les coupes et brushing effectuez les
soins et traitements capillaires gérer
votre poste de travail pour postuler
vous devez impérativement être titulaire
d'un CAP coiffure
le coiffeur ou la coiffeuse doit savoir
exercer un diagnostic capillaire
connaître les tendances mode en matière
de coiffure maîtriser les techniques de
couple coloration et coiffure avoir la
fibre commerciale et savoir être à
l'écoute et conseiller la clientèle
bonjour je m'appelle Alex de Louvigny
j'habite à Sainte-Clotilde j'ai 25 ans
et je recherche un poste dans le secteur
du marketing je recherche un poste plus
dans le Nord donc 5 Clotilde Saint-Denis
Sainte-Marie moi j'ai passé un bac sur
cette technologie de gestion spécialité
marketing je suis parti en métropole
après l'acquisition de mon bac un petit
peu pour me trouver voir un petit peu ce
que je désirais faire dans la vie j'ai
touché un peu à tout j'ai tenté de
monter mon entreprise un moment dans le
traitement de la corrosion en Atlantique
ça a beaucoup de problèmes de corrosion
à la Réunion aussi d'ailleurs sinon j'ai
une expérience aussi en centre d'appel
j'ai travaillé un an pour pour une
entreprise qui s'appelle mdoi marketing
direct au salon indien où je faisais des
enquêtes de satisfaction je répondais
pour des clients sous-traitants c'était
intéressant j'ai travaillé dans le
prêt-à-porter donc aujourd'hui je
recherche un BTS en alternance de 18
vers commercial toujours et je cherche
une entreprise justement pour pouvoir le
passer je parle créole oui je comprends
très bien le créole parfaitement je le
parle en fonction de mon Inter Twitter
c'est sûr concentré d'appel on a toutes
sortes de gens c'est la population de
façon réunionnaise donc il faut répondre
à la demande et surtout qui nous
comprennent donc c'est un atout je pense
de pouvoir s'exprimer en français comme
en créole anglais espagnol bon j'ai un
niveau moyen et après c'est une question
de pratique je sais me servir de
l'informatique je sais faire des
recherches sur internet pour savoir ce
qui m'intéresse ce qui a à prendre
facilité voilà internet informatique
c'est un bon outil il faut savoir s'en
servir je suis assez observateur je suis
attentif à l'écoute j'arrive en général
à distinguer les
les états émotionnels de mes
interlocuteurs pour pouvoir m'adapter je
suis un bon communicant donc voilà
éventuellement un poste en centre
d'appel mais je reste aussi ouvert à
toute proposition si mon profil
d'aventure vous intéresserait si je vous
remercie beaucoup de votre attention
mais je restais ouvert à toute
propositions de votre part je suis
intéressé
si vous l'êtes aussi ben contactez-moi
contactez-nous sur votre page Facebook
le
www.facebook.com/974tv ou par téléphone
0262 92 37 60
9 7 4 CV votre émission au service de
l'emploi à la Réunion